so first up could I get your full name
will Steven well Steven
he hasn't been in asking about Jared
Leto's hair what do you think about
Jared Leto's hair you know about wait
why do you ask that because we're
looking at your Facebook in this van
right here are you gonna go let's do it
ask my privacy question so we're asking
people about is how public they are on
social media and what they think about
just online privacy general do you
consider yourself like a private person
yeah so she's an actress like if you get
like a part on like Riz Anatomy Grey's
Anatomy or something would you share
that how did you know I don't you know I
don't want to see them like what they
ate you eat grits figure out be eating
grits would you post about that on your
Facebook's I put a picture of grits up
once yes yeah she went to NYU so you
moved out here from NYU I got from New
York do you three genetic diversity so
what do you say like genetic diversity
yes that's actually exactly what I said
interesting she broke her index finger
so you're into music right well you're
in a bunch of bands is a guitarist in
planeswalker
like when planeswalker play shows you
want to bring out your other friends to
see this part of your life
wait a second what her dad is Mike and
I'm on with Gabriella okay so like you
don't want Mike and Gabriella watching
your Instagram exactly how do you know
that it's very easy to find out where
people live and like just from their
social media like the fact that you in
like
no that's creepy though he's kind of
creepy isn't it yes so your brother
Christian you mostly look at his
Facebook right what what about your boy
like auntie he post too much okay so you
don't you want to like connect with your
friends like look using Facebook what
you know like going back to Alexandria
Virginia what the no this is really
weird
this is weird this is weird you guys are
weird amazing it's totally crazy say
hello to everybody that's terrifying
thank you you knew that is that